Hi, how are you doing?
In this lesson, we'll be exploring parent and instance
materials, as well as expanding their features to make
them a bit more dynamic.
All right, let's get started.
So before diving into the creation of these materials,
I just wanted to emphasize that it is a common production
practice to first create the parent materials,
and then their child or instance materials.
And those instance materials will be the ones
applied to the objects, not their parents.
This will allow you to be faster at iterating the materials,
because A, instance materials don't
need to be recompiled whenever you change them,
and B, if you need to make some drastic changes to how
your whole environment was shaded because, I don't know,
your director had a different vision
for the look of the roughness of the materials, for example.
If most of it derives from two or three master materials,
then you'll just need to change those two or three,
and these changes will be applied like a cascade
to all their children or instance materials.
So this is a very optimized and efficient way
of working with materials in Unreal Engine,
and I would highly recommend it, actually.
OK, let's take a look at an example in Engine now.
All right, we are in the Expanding Material Features
section of our map, which should be fired up
whenever you open the project for the first time.
And this is our sample material for the class.
If we click on the Preview Mesh,
you can find downhill in the Details panel the material
that is assigned to it, and if you double-click on this,
it will open up the material.
But it looks a little different than any other material
we're used to because there is no graph, no nodes,
no setup, and that's because this is actually
an instant material.
And these kind of materials are really useful
because they expose different parameters that we can just
turn on and off to enable and disable,
and then we can just change them on the fly.
So we could be changing these textures to a different one
if we wanted to.
We could be enabling the albedo, the normal, or the roughness
map, and we could also be changing the offset
and the tiling of these maps.
Now, down here, we have this metallic question mark,
and this is not Unreal Engine talking to us.
This is actually something that we set up.
And if we turn it on, for example,
you can see that it will enable a metalness map as well
as the metalness intensity parameter
that we can just adjust as we want.
And if we turn metallic off, you
can see that these two different parameters are swapped
for the base metallic value, which
acts as a basically full, flat black and white texture that
increases or decreases the metalness of the material.
OK, so this metallic question mark
is actually named a static switch parameter,
and it is pretty useful at optimizing environments,
for example, because you can turn off a set of textures
if they're not needed.
So let's go back to the slides for just a second
before building this material up in the engine.
OK, so each step that I will be taking now
in Unreal during the demo will also
be displayed through screenshots and instructions
here in the slides, so you can easily follow along.
And together with the sample material
that we just saw, the instance one,
as well as its parent material, you
should be able to just walk in the right direction
as we draft these materials out.
OK, so let's just jump back into the engine
and build our static switch parameter,
as well as some few more nodes to make our materials
a bit more dynamic.
Let's go.
OK, I'm going to be keeping this instance material open,
and then I'm going to go back to my viewport.
And then I will be creating a new material in the content
browser.
I'm going to be calling it m underscore demo,
but you can call it whatever you want,
and then double-click to open it up.
OK, so this graph is completely empty,
but we have already gone through building
a simple material from the ground
up in the previous classes, so we won't be going over it
again in this class.
So to make our life easier, we'll
be just stealing some nodes from the sample material instead.
In order to do that, I will just
go back to our instance material,
and down here I can find the parent material where
this child originates from.
So I will just double-click here to open it up.
OK, so this set of nodes of this parent material
is also ultimately what we'll try to build today.
So you can use that to guide you along.
And by the way, over here you have
a bit of a more complex set of nodes to set up the albedo.
So you can look this up if you want to.
Keep in mind that this setup is using two material
functions, which are the blend overly and the shift contrast,
and we'll go over material functions
in the last class of this course.
OK, now let's just pan back and shift-drag the albedo
sets of nodes, and then Control and click the metalness,
and then Control-C to copy these whole sets of nodes
to borrow it.
Then we'll go back to the material demo,
and Control-V here in the empty graph to paste them.
OK, so we won't be applying any further changes
to the albedo setup, so we can just
take the output pin of the lerp
and then connect it to the base color.
And by the way, we'll be looking into the functionality
of the lerp or linear interpolate node
in the next class when we start developing mass
materials.
OK, let's just go on and expand a little bit more
the functionalities of our metalness.
So first of all, what we want to do
is adding a scalar parameter down here
and call it metallic intensity.
All right, so before moving on in the development
of our material, I just wanted to highlight
the difference between scalar parameter and constant values.
Because if I press 1 on the keyboard
and then click on the graph, I will create a constant value.
If I press S and left click on the graph,
I will create a scalar parameter.
And both of them actually output single float values.
But the difference between them
is that the constant value is not
exposed to material instances while the scalar parameter is.
And that's really the only difference.
But you can convert one to the other
easily by right clicking on them
and then converting to constant for the scalar.
Or for the constant value, you can just right click on it
and then convert to parameter.
So they're easily interchangeable.
OK, now let's just move on and add a multiply node
by pressing M on the keyboard and left clicking on the graph.
Then collect the RGB value of the metalness map with the A
and then the metallic intensity to the B.
We'll then create another scalar parameter
by hitting S on the keyboard, and we'll call it base metal.
And this will just be a flat black and white metallic
texture applied to the whole material.
OK, so now we want a way to switch
between the metallic texture and intensity group of nodes
and the base metal scalar parameter.
And in order to do that, we will add,
if I right click on the graph, a static switch parameter.
And we'll call it metallic question mark.
So do we want the metallic texture to be on or off?
So we'll just connect the multiply node to the true
and then the base metal scalar parameter to the false.
So the static switch parameter will
allow us to flip between using the texture
and the intensity or just one base flat black and white
texture to set up the metalness.
So then we can just plug the output pin of the metallic
to the metallic input of the material.
OK, let's just apply these changes, save,
and then we will control spacebar
and create a misnus material of this parent material.
By the way, they're called parent materials,
but they're actually just generic materials.
I call them parents because we will be creating instance
materials out of them, and they will be their children,
so they're parents to me.
All right, so let's right click on the material demo
and then create a material instance.
And the naming convention for material instances
is usually MI for material instance underscore,
whatever you want to call it, in this case, demo.
OK, then I will double click to open it up,
and I will just dock it over here.
So the first thing I want to test out
is whether the metallic static switch parameter is working.
So in order to turn the switch parameter on,
we first need to enable it.
So I will just enable it from here on the left,
and then I can just turn it on from here with the tick
box.
OK, so once it's turned on, it's working as we need it
because it's displaying the metalness texture that we
can just swap on the fly, and it's also enabling
the metallic intensity scaler.
By the way, these two scaler parameters
are not grouped correctly, but that's fine
because we already talked about grouping
in the previous classes.
So we won't be looking into that today.
There's going to be a little bit organized, but that's fine.
OK, then if we turn off metallic,
you can see that the base metal parameter is turned on,
and this will really act as a flat texture.
All right, so let's just keep this material instance open
and go back to our paint material.
Now we'll be creating a set of nodes
to be able to dynamically control the UV tiling
and offset of our texture.
So let's just pan a little bit more to the left,
and then if we right-click in an empty area of the graph,
we can add a texture coordinate node.
And the texture coordinates will let
us control how our texture will map into our model.
After that, we want to add a scaler parameter that we
will call Tiling Overall.
And the tiling of a texture really
defines how it is scaled.
So let's turn it to 1, else it's just
going to be scaled to 0.
OK, so now we want to be multiplying the texture
coordinates with the tiling.
So I'm going to press M, and left-clicking the graph,
and then connect the texture coordinate to the A,
and then the tiling to the B.
So this set of nodes lets us have a very generic kind
of control over our textures, but we
can get a little bit more granular
by adding two more scalar parameters.
And we'll call one Offset U, turn it on to 1,
and then Offset V, and turn it on to 1.
So the Offset U and V will let us control individually
the x and y vectors of our texture,
where the U controls the horizontal axis left to right,
and the V controls the vertical axis bottom to top.
OK, these two scalar parameters, as we just said,
output single float values.
But the texture coordinate nodes work with vector 2 values.
So we need a way to combine these two scalar parameters
together.
And there is a really useful node for that,
which is called Append Node.
So if I drag out of the Offset U and an Append Vector Node,
if I Control-Alt, Undo will tell me what this node does,
and basically allows me to combine channels together
to create a vector with more channels than the original,
which is actually what we need.
OK, so now we have two different options.
We can either multiply these two nodes or add them.
Using the Add Node, we will be shuffling the U and V
values very linearly without any scaling or distortion,
while using the Multiply Node,
they will actually scale a little bit.
And I actually think that the Multiply Node usually
looks a little bit more natural, so I will just
go with that for now.
So let's connect the Multiply Node to the A
and the Append Node to the B. And I will keep the Add Node
here for now, because I want to show you the difference
between using the two.
So then we want to connect the Multiply Output
Pane to the UVs of the Albedo Map and the Metallus.
OK, let's just test this out by applying.
And then I will just undock the Material Instance,
because I want to show the difference between multiplying
and applying.
So I will expand this a little bit,
and I will set the Preview Mode to Plane up here,
just so that this is a little bit clearer.
And then I will enable the Offset U, Offset V,
and the Tiling Overall.
So the Tiling Overall, as we just said,
is just a very generic scaling of the Texture.
And then the Offset U will just
stretch it in the horizontal axis
and the V in the vertical axis.
OK, so this is how multiplying them looks like.
Now let's switch back to adding them instead
in the Material demo.
And if I Control and hold left-click,
I can just drag this Input Pin.
And I can do the same with the B
and with the output of the Multiply.
So remember that we need to apply these changes.
And now, as you can see, there is no more stretching
on the Texture whenever we Offset U and Offset V.
So it's way more linear.
All right, so that was it for this class.
I hope you enjoyed it.
And in the next one, we will be
learning about Mask Materials.
So stick around, because it's going to be pretty cool.